It is very difficult to change
somebody's first impression of you, and
that's no different when it comes to
public speaking. In fact, an audience
will often judge whether a speaker is
strong or weak within the first few
seconds of what they do on stage. And in
this video, I'm going to give you a few
of the tips of how you can ensure they
think of you as a strong speaker versus
a weak speaker. You can tell a strong
speaker from a weak speaker in the first
20 seconds based on what they do with
their eyes.
So, when a weak speaker comes up and is
introduced and comes to the front of the
room,
first off, often they'll be using the
lectern and they'll be reading notes and
they'll be looking down and rarely
engaging with eye contact.
And if they're a slightly stronger
speaker, they may detach from the
lectern, but they'll be looking up and
down often.
When they're looking down, it may be a
lack of confidence. They may be trying
to remember the place they are in their
speech. And when they're looking up,
this certainly signifies thinking,
definitely trying to capture their
thought or whatever it is that they're
supposed to be talking about next.
But strong speakers,
they are intentional with eye contact.
They scan the room.
They ensure
that they make eye contact with everyone
in that room because eye contact creates
accountability.
When an audience member sees you making
eye contact with them, they're more
likely to stay engaged. And what the
really strong speakers can do
is they can finish a thought on eye
contact. So, rather than constant
scanning throughout the room, they will
finish one single point
with eye contact with one person. And as
they move on to the next idea, they'll
lock in with another person and finish
that thought. That is one of the
quickest ways to tell a strong speaker
from a weak speaker.
It's what they do with their eyes. How
can you tell a strong public speaker
from a weak public speaker within the
first 20 seconds?
It's what they do with their feet.
For many speakers who are more on the
amateur side,
they will feel uncomfortable and there
will be a swaying of the weight back and
forth on the feet or there will be some
sort of nervous tendency or perhaps
they're leaning or they're kicking their
foot or they're moving back and forth.
And sometimes they might not even
realize that they're doing these various
things with their feet,
but it's that nervous energy.
What strong speakers will do
is they'll stay planted.
They'll be calm, they'll be confident.
That doesn't mean they won't move. They
will move, but it will be intentional
movement.
And they'll include it with the eye
contact.
And when they're finishing a thought,
they'll stay in that place. And then
when they move on to another thought,
they'll physically move their body and
then they'll stay planted.
And they will use their movements to aid
in whatever it is that they're talking
about.
So if you are a newer speaker, really
focus on what you're doing with your
feet. Record yourself giving a
presentation. And if you notice that
you're swaying back and forth or you're
leaning or you have a crossed leg or
you're tapping your foot,
focus on that.
Be more intentional. Keep those feet
steady, less distracting for the
audience, and move with purpose. How can
you tell a strong speaker from a weak
speaker within the first 20 seconds that
they're on stage?
What are they doing with their hands?
Weaker speakers will often rely on a
lectern, and so they will probably be
holding it with their hands and gripping
them gripping the side of the lectern
quite tight, and they may be reading
notes or they may be presenting, but
they'll feel the safety net of needing
to hold on to something.
Slightly stronger speakers,
but those who are probably still on the
weak side,
might have their hands in their pockets
as they're presenting.
They have that nervous energy, and they
don't want their hands to be out. Some
speakers may cross their arms,
but what strong speakers will do is
they'll use their hands to engage the
audience's attention.
And what really strong speakers will do
is they will allow the hands to be at
their side when they're not using them,
and then bring them up periodically when
it makes sense to add to what they're
saying, and then they'll allow those
hands to fall back to the side, and then
once again bring them up strategically.
What many speakers get guilty of is
something called the invisible table,
and so they keep their arms at this 90°
angle, and they will use their hand
gestures, but it will never fall below
this invisible table. And the problem
with that is again, it becomes a little
bit distracting and not natural. But if
you were guilty of this, I want you to
break through that invisible table.
Allow the arms to the side and bring
them up, and this is a quick way to
identify yourself as a strong speaker
versus a weaker speaker. How can you
tell an amateur speaker from a more
polished or professional speaker within
the first few seconds?
Well, what's the content?
How do they start their speech? If they
open their speech by saying, "Hey
everyone, my name is Wade. Today I'm
going to be talking to you about social
media.
We're going to go over a few different
tips and tricks that I found are
beneficial."
If that's how the speaker starts,
it's not the worst speaker, but it's
definitely not somebody who has elite
skills. Those who have elite skills
don't start with the general formalities
with introducing themselves. They start
with jumping right into a story,
telling a powerful statistic,
or in some cases asking a
thought-provoking question.
If you could only be on one social media
network,
which social media network would you
choose to be on?
Or,
did you know 80% of videos on social
media are viewed without the sound on?
So, if you're making video content and
not including subtitles,
only 20% of people are getting the
context.
Or,
when I was in 11th grade,
I had my first experience with social
media,
and it was one of my most embarrassing
moments.
By starting speeches this way, it's
instantly more interesting. You're
providing value up front, and it
disrupts a pattern that people are so
used to the formal introductions. This
is what separates amateur speakers from
pros. Can you as a speaker grab the
audience's attention within the first
few seconds? If not, there's a better
way to intro your speech. What is one of
the quickest ways to identify whether
someone is a weak speaker versus a
strong speaker?
Um well, uh
one of the um one of the ways to to know
whether they're um
a little bit weaker is um
are they using those filler words?
Filler words are sounds or words such as
uh um and so but basically they're any
word or sound that is injected in
between sentences
which does not add any value to what
you're saying. If you replace them, it
would not take away any of the quality
from your sentences.
The reason we use filler words is
because it becomes uncomfortable when
we're standing in front of a room of
people. We feel like we have to
constantly be talking and um we uh
uh uh uh
fill the gaps with these filler words.
What more polished presenters know
is that silence is okay.
In fact, in some ways it's more
enjoyable to listen to
and that you can use silence to really
allow thoughts to sink in.
How do you eliminate your filler words?
Step number one is understanding what
filler words you use. Very common ones
are uh and um. You can do this by
recording yourself. You can attend a
Toastmasters meeting where they have a
role that's called the ah counter who
gives a report at the end of the meeting
to tell you what filler words you used.
That's step one. Step two, you're going
to start catching yourself saying those
filler words.
And I don't want you to panic when you
do.
Just have that little mental note.
There it is.
You have built a habit of using a filler
word in between sentences. We're going
to build a new habit and that is
replacing the filler words with silence.
It's going to make you sound more
polished, more professional and your
audience will lean in and engage even
more. I hope this video on some of the
ways to identify whether a speaker is
strong or more on the amateur side
within the first few seconds was
beneficial to you. Let me know in the
comments. Are there any here that you're
guilty of personally? What have you made
strides with perhaps over your speaking
journey? Would love to get the
conversation started. And if you have
not already done so, please subscribe to
my channel. It is the best way for you
to get free content that is relevant to
helping make you a more confident and
polished public speaker. Check out the
video YouTube is recommending and thank
you so much for watching this video.